hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video on order
flow and you know what I want to talk
about today some of the interesting
things in the order flow from this past
week uh mainly in the crude oil and gold
now in the crude oil on Friday the 20th
there was uh you know an interesting
sign of absorption when we got up to
that high of 81.91 just around one
o'clock Chicago time and
let me just pull up the chart here so
this is the footprint chart okay and you
can see the volumes coming in up here at
the high we had the high of the day and
you've got a nice strong positive Delta
384. you've actually got a Delta surge
going into this High you have the
negative 19 Delta here in this red
candle and then positive Delta 52
positive Delta 117 positive Delta of 384
which on the surface if you're just
looking at the Delta and how it's
increasing you're thinking hey this is
bullish we should be going higher but
that's why I always say you know you
have to watch also not just the order
flow not just focusing on the Delta you
also need to be focusing on how price is
acting right it's not just taking the
order Flow by itself you got to be
putting the order flow which is
essentially the volume that you're
analyzing on the bid and the offer side
together with how price is moving along
with it right not just well I've got
positive more positive even more
positive I got get long because we're
going to break 82 bucks and you know go
to you know 80 82.50 because what is
happening up in here why you have this
big positive Delta notice the bar it's a
red candle right it's not a green candle
if this was a green candle and we were
closing up somewhere near the high of
the bar yeah I'd be very bullish now
this is a one minute chart on crude oil
and what happened is in the first half
of the bar
it was very bullish right you're trading
up near the high of the day at the high
of the day you got nice strong positive
Delta you ran into some nice resting
liquidity up here you could see even at
the high it's 62 below it it's 182 below
it is 126. and you know at one point in
this bar you're looking at very strong
Delta of plus 476 that's the max Delta
so it's telling me the strongest that
Delta was in this bar was positive 476
you had 476 more aggressive buyers than
aggressive sellers however
first
action started to diverge because what
is happening is now the market is
starting to sell off so even though you
had that very strong positive Delta
early
price is rejecting these high levels up
here at 81.91 right and what you saw is
you saw that resting liquidity there
absorbing all that aggressive buying
that was taking place
how do I know obviously the most obvious
sign is the bar closed on its low right
you sort of have this bar Divergence
right between price action and the Delta
and it's actually even though you got
the strong positive Delta it's actually
a bearish signal okay because what's
happening is that resting liquidity was
up there to absorb that buying that was
transacting at the at these new highs
but once it absorbed all that buying
activity all that aggressiveness in the
market
and there was no more aggressive buying
what do you think that's going to happen
to price it's going to drop and what was
interesting is once it dropped you don't
see as much volume taking place you know
on the bottom half of the bar as you saw
on the top half of the bar
and what happens the market starts
selling off from you know this 8180 area
we get back down into the 60s and you
know eventually down into the 50s down
in here okay and you know eventually we
did actually I think go up and take out
that high or get back up there near the
oh here on the reopen on Sunday night we
got up near the high of Friday but you
know on Sunday night we just continued
selling off so you know just because
you're at the high of the day and you've
got you know positive Delta coming in
you still need to take a look at what is
happening with price okay because that
was the big tell and you know people
like to
uh compare trading to things like poker
you know and there's certain tells
in poker right that just give away
another Trader it's almost like the
market is bluffing up here that it wants
to go higher and then the giveaway was
what price was doing price was moving
down had price stayed up here near the
high yeah chances are we could still go
higher because that would be a sign that
there's still some aggressive buying in
the market it just wasn't there now
also on Thursday actually I I didn't
talk about this on on Thursday evening
but in the gold right you remember gold
started making new highs Thursday you
know it's it's you know it really looks
like gold wants to break 2 000. who
knows maybe it'll do it this week you
know 2000 is going to be a big level
Peter Schiff I'm sure will be very
excited at these levels I'm sure he's
excited right now but gold was going up
okay on Thursday okay you can see we had
this High coming in here at 1927 we had
just made a new high at 27 and a half
this was at 12 41. you know we've been
going higher pretty much all day and
there was still more to this move you
know we made this high up here at 12 41
came off and just went sideways we
didn't really pull back very much but
this High here when we started breaking
out it was doing it
tremendously okay how what do I mean by
tremendously what's the sign is well we
took out the high
okay and you see a big bid coming here
136 fresh buying 179 fresh buying the
414 so it's not only is it breaking out
to these new highs it's clearing out
whatever offers are here and it's gone
bid bid for 136 bid for 179 bid for 400
bid for 199.
all right so you can understand that
this momentum that is taking place in
the market
is probably pretty strong right there's
not only do you have you know people
think that you know markets only
will go up when there's you know
aggressive buying okay and yeah you that
is the most important part you need some
aggressive buying but when you have
the passive buying coming in here right
the passive bids the 136 the 179 to help
support this Market on its way up to new
highs
you know that's the best the best thing
that you could ask for right it'd be
like the opposite would be as the market
is selling down when you see Supply
coming into the market okay I don't want
to call this in a sense Demand right
because you know when you think of
demand you think of coming in at Lowe's
but when you have this demand coming in
at highs people coming into the market
bidding the market right when we're
taking out highs you know people always
talk about you know the institutional
Traders the retail Traders
um
you know and you know and sort of the
differences right when you're breaking
out the new highs
and it's sort of being
run up by you know retail Traders
Traders you know fear of missing out
they're fomoing you know they're just
tripping over themselves to buy it
they're not trying to finesse their
their order by you know working a bid at
uh 28 working another bit at you know
28th and 2860 another one appear at
29.30 they just get me in you know they
just buy just buy the offer that they
think is going higher but when you sort
of see these calculated bids coming in
at levels
um 28 28 60 29 30 and for big size
that's the important thing right because
what's happening
we're making new highs on negative Delta
and price is still going higher
so
what do you think that means you know
people say well you got new highs you
got negative Delta I shouldn't the
market start to sell off because you got
that aggressive selling okay but price
is still going higher
and not only that you could just see all
right look at the footprint chart that's
the whole point of using a footprint
chart is to see how the volume transact
on the bids and offers and if you see
big bids coming in after Highs are made
what do you think that's telling you
that's Market is screaming at you that
there's supportive buying coming into
this Market to sort of arrest any move
coming down right you can just draw
these lines from these big or these big
bid levels are here here here
okay what do we do the rest of the day
even up here I mean you got one here you
got the 199 I'd even care about that one
or this 321. I'll see I see this 136
coming in here I see the 179 that's my
clue enough then you get that parabolic
bar right here which just jumps up from
you know 29 all the way up to 32. let's
say parabolic but you know a nice big
move up parabolic is a bit hyperbole
there but it's a nice move up you know a
nice three dollar move
um
very quickly you know obviously on heavy
volume but look at these levels here 20
28 28 and a half or 2860 rather 29 20.
you can see what happened I mean later
in the day we still made new highs okay
where we come back down to test do we
test this first level here all right we
get all the way up all the way up to
36.90 you know around two o'clock
hit with gold that's about the time you
should if you trade it during the US
hours that's about the time you should
close your book for the day you know
then the next evening session we
reopened on Friday evening right we're
still trading all the way up you know
35.
but you got these levels here 31
30 10 29 20. you know where you could
see some potential support right so and
we still go higher right all the way up
to 36.
okay then it comes down
eight o'clock gets right down to this
level
you can see it bounces a bit from there
it just hangs around that first level
finally it breaks through breaks through
the next level breaks through this next
level all right then this level here is
holding so you can see how these
areas of that strong support of buying
acting as support when the markets you
know continue to trade into the next
session not just because you have these
support levels you know it doesn't mean
it's going to hold forever like oh we
just broke through you know we created
this level here at one in the afternoon
you know what time was that
you know 125 and it's going to magically
hold for the rest of goal's life no you
know at some point you're going to come
down we're going to test it and
eventually we're going to break it but
when you have these levels and you see
the market tested here
here and it's holding you know these are
strong levels
Okay so
the absorption comes in different forms
okay so this is also a sign of
absorption these strong passive bids
coming in
as we're making new highs because what
you have is you have buyers these times
this time it's it's passive buyers
coming in there to absorb whatever
people want to sell to them at the new
highs
just as in crude right when we got up
here made these new highs you had that
liquidity there that this is resting
liquidity as opposed to what you're
seeing in the gold which is whoops the
wrong gold chart but this is the
new liquidity that's coming into the
market which one is stronger
well you could debate it until cows come
home but it's liquidity it's liquidity
that's coming in to absorb in this case
whatever selling is taking place whereas
here you have liquidity resting
liquidity absorbing whatever buying is
taking place whatever aggressive buying
is taking place so you know I just want
you to realize that you know absorption
comes in different forms okay
at highs of the day you know we saw
um buying liquidity buying absorption
and we saw selling absorption one day in
the crude one day in the gold so
I hope you guys get something out of
this video I hope you enjoyed it if you
did be sure to subscribe to the channel
and smash the like button thanks
everyone bye-bye